ça fait cinq ans que je fais des écoles
de formation pour les jeunes chômeurs
on n'a jamais réussi une seule fois
faire venir une caméra de télévision on
forme 2000 par an 2000 parents des mômes
qui étaient au chômage sans boulot coin
un boulot pourquoi parce que ça vous
intéresse pas le sujet qui intéresse
tapis dans les médias c'est pas ça ces
euros c'est le cowboy c'est le Charlot
c'est le guignol c'est pas le type qu'on
voit des gens à lui pour former des
mômes donc si je suis en décalage avec
l'idée que vous avez vous de tapis et
surtout à juste titre l'idée que les
clients de vos médias ont ça vous
intéresse pas vous laissez quand même
moyen de promettre à des gosses qui
pourront être de grands footballeurs
professionnels
de 11 ans qui seront de grands
footballeurs professionnels
je trouve malhonnête quand on vient
faire de la démagogie comme ça à
Montfermeil je vous êtes un pauvre
vous pouvez pas c'est pas possible
vous allez en prendre combien parce que
figurez-vous vous avez des enfants
vous avez des enfants vous en avez des
enfants eux ils ont une chance et
pouvoir voir leur père en se disant
peut-être que je vais être comme lui et
peut-être qu'il y sera laissez-moi finir
pas du tout peut-être qu'il a cette
chose de se dire
que
l'espérance c'est votre attitude
mais moi moi c'est une question de faire
du péché il y a rien à faire Bernard moi
j'ai été ça de la démagogie sur le
terrain vous empêcher et vous il faut
impérativement au métier dans la tête
que quand des gosses quand des gosses et
des adolescents sont privés de la
moindre parcelle d'espoir c'est à dire
qu'il reste plus aucune chance d'espérer
quoi que ce soit ne croyez pas que vous
arrivez même avec un emploi vous arrivez
avec un emploi il le garde pas vous le
faites travailler une semaine il perd
son boulot donc il y a deux solutions on
les met en cage ça c'est sûrement ce que
vous préférez et la deuxième solution
c'est qu'on commence en même temps à
mettre en place des dispositifs qui leur
donnent accès au savoir mais qui leur
donne aussi un petit peu l'espérance
parce que si on leur donne pas ça et moi
je vais vous rappeler quelques et vous
leur expliquer des emplois chez Adidas
Bernard Tapie simplement moi attendez
attendez attendez
attendez Bernard
c'est Noël le Great le président de la
ligue qui a décréé à quelques jours que
vous allez plus présider l'Olympique de
Marseille le 9 c'est-à-dire après demain
c'est vrai déjà après-demain
et vous pourrez tenir même quand les
chiffres de l'audit dont on parle sur le
déficit de Marseille était là pourquoi
vous êtes une boîte aux lettres en fait
c'est une boîte aux lettres c'est génial
j'ai l'impression d'être en face une
revue de presse
vous pouvez pas avoir votre avis
de donner des ordres c'est pas une faire
des exposés c'est pas une question c'est
une affirmation j'ai dit puisque vous
avez la chance je suis là vous me
demandez je vais vous dire quel est le
déficit comme je l'ai toujours dit
depuis le premier jour donc les chiffres
qu'on annonce 200 320 faux 100 millions
voilà et comment on en est arrivé à 100
millions que je sois là si c'est
ce que vous dites tout le temps quand on
n'y est pas mais ne me dites pas vous à
propos à propos de ceci
je suis pas l'ensemble et quand je parle
à tapis je parle pas l'ensemble des
présidents de club c'est 100 millions
voilà et et comme vous savez pourquoi ça
justement parce que ça représente ce
qu'on aurait gagné sur la fin de Coupe
d'Europe
le commentaire qu'il a fait c'est pas
bien faut pas faire des commentaires
comme ça il y a rien qui m'arrêtera je
voudrais vous dire ici Monsieur si ces
gens s'imaginent que c'est de me faire
des lunes de ce genre qui sont
systématiquement annoncés à quelques
jours des grands événements politiques
l'événement politique qui arrive c'est
le Congrès des radicaux dans trois jours
à chaque fois faut qu'ils disent que
c'est trop tard ce mouvement qui est
derrière moi ne s'arrêtera pas et même
si leur prend la mauvaise idée de
vouloir me mettre là où tout le monde
espère ceux qui sont pas de manquants ça
changera rien j'incarne des millions de
gens qui en ont marre que ce pouvoir qui
a été pris séquestré par des gens qui
s'autoproclament et qui sont défendus
par des complices parce qu'ils sont dans
la même mayonnaise ils viennent du même
endroit ça ne suffira pas à m'arrêter
Bernard Tapie on va passer à l'autre
affaire sur le crédit je voudrais
simplement vous dire que c'est une
affaire sur l'affaire libération je veux
dire on imagine mal quand même un
mensonge total monsieur
avant-hier sur vos meubles et
aujourd'hui vous leur
vous savez je vais vous dire quelque
chose vous avez la journée pendant
laquelle je pense que les autorités
judiciaires qui sont montrées attendez
outrés les syndicats des entreprises qui
sont outrés vont réagir bon le drame
c'est que si on est aux États-Unis c'est
100 millions de dollars de dommages
intérêt là vous savez ce que ça va faire
30 millions de francs dans 5 ans c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent continuer vous savez
hier monsieur milalliance
dans le monde dans le monde il y a une
page entière qui sont un mot près les
conclusions de l'avocat du Crédit
Lyonnais mais quel scandale c'est une
onde ils sont à moi si je les perds
c'est pas grave monsieur bilalium
vous nous avez dit dans un premier temps
c'est complètement faux ce que vous
dites
c'est toujours complètement faux et vous
nous avez pas dit vous aviez déjà par
exemple
je vais vous attaquez encore parce qu'il
y a pas de faux chez moi il y a pas de
fauche il y a pas de fauche il y en a
pas de faux chez moi
si on peut plus croire personne on dit
plus jamais rien à nous faux il y a pas
un seul moi je dis vous dites le
contraire ah bon très bien vous savez ce
que vous dites dans la presse il est dit
que vous passez votre temps à vous
relire à vous auto proclamer il y en a
pas un faut mais c'est pas un problème
vous savez que pendant 10 ans entre 20
ans entre 20 ans et 30 ans il y en a eu
des faux et j'étais très heureux de les
regarder quand même non mais ça c'est
parce que moi
aujourd'hui vous me donnez une
information
allez-y puisque apparemment depuis hier
j'entends les spéculations sur les
problèmes du Lyonnais allez-y oui
revenons-en à la deuxième le problème du
Lyonnais c'est de savoir si un contrat
entre moi et qui va être bon ou pas je
vous rassure s'il est pas bon c'est pas
grave parce que s'il est pas bon il
donne naissance de nouveau à celui qu'il
précédait car ce que vous savez pas
c'est que l'histoire du Lyonnais elle
est pas né que j'allais des difficultés
elle est née parce que quand on est
ministre on peut pas en même temps être
président d'une affaire qui conduit 12
13 14 000 personnes et occupaient ces
fonctions là donc il a été décidé par
l'ensemble des actionnaires que je ne
pouvais pas continuer à garantir ces
responsabilités là ce que je comprends
pas c'est que la Cour d'appel il y en a
plein de choses que vous comprenez pas
en 2005 vous avez donné raison qui avait
estimé que vous aviez été bel et bien
floué par le Crédit Lyonnais cette cour
d'appel elle avait stimé votre préjudice
moral non pas du tout 1 euro elle vous
avait accordé un euro de préjudice moral
vous dites n'importe quoi car le
préjudice avait pas encore été tranché
figurez-vous qu'elle dit une expertise
devra déterminer le montant du préjudice
voilà exactement ce qu'elle dit la cour
d'appel bon je reviens attendez non non
mais je vais vous expliquer si je n'ai
ici parce que vous avez l'impression que
vous avez réussi à faire un numéro
qu'aucun a fait vous vous trompez non
c'est vous qui faites-le faire la course
la commission des finances comme vous à
dit il va falloir qu'on lui fasse
affaire et ils ont préparé leur truc
vous pouvez pas faire la fête car ça
repose sur rien ça fait 15 ans que j'ai
raison et ça fait 15 ans que ça vous
emmerde que j'ai raison parce que depuis
le départ depuis le départ vous avezimé
que je vais avoir tort voilà alors il
faudra vous y faire vous mourrez avec ça
j'ai gagné 45 plus un peu plus encore et
vous en êtes content plus ça vous
emmerde plus ça me fait plaisir et ça
vous fait plaisir ça on peut l'imaginer
avez-vous plus je sens que ça vous
emmerde et plus ça me fait plaisir
personnellement
mais je sais que ça vous fait ça vous
fait chier le Seigneur
votre question de départ simplement
avez-vous reçu le chèque du fils ça ne
vous regarde pas j'ai pas envie de vous
le dire donc secret fiscal nous disent
les ministres et secrets tout court nous
dit Bernard Tapie voilà et moi je vous
demande pas combien vous gagnez je vous
demande pas comment vous payer d'impôts
et je m'en fous oui mais la différence
franchement on a pas je m'en fous ça
m'intéresse pas on n'est pas dans la la
même situation ça c'est vrai vous savez
la différence entre nous deux vous avez
passé votre vie raconter ce que font les
autres
c'est ma dernière question pourquoi
avez-vous le sentiment à ce point d'être
persécuté comme s'il y avait un des
médias des juges des politiques est-ce
que vous imaginez un seul instant que on
essaye de dire le droit regardez c'est
ce que j'ai dit juste avant de rentrer
quand un journaliste sait plus quoi dire
parce qu'il est conscient qu'il y a une
acharnement incroyable il dit mais alors
c'est un complot et nous comme des
imbéciles on n'a pas envie de dire oui
parce qu'on passe aux imbéciles oui
monsieur c'est un complot c'est un
complot je vais vous dire comment mais
je vais vous l'expliquer c'est très
simple
le soir de la victoire de la coupe du
monde de football
qui a été gagné par une équipe dans
laquelle il y avait plus de la moitié
qui était des Marseillais j'ai essayé
d'avoir une invitation pour la finale
j'ai essayé partout la Ligue la
Fédération partout j'ai pas le droit à
une invitation et puis Deschamps quand
on lui emmène trophée la première
déclaration il dit cette coupe de monde
on la doit Berlin tapis il y a deux
France Monsieur il y a la France de ceux
qui ont le droit et la France de ce
comparois la Fédération m'a pas invité à
assister à la finale et des champs m'a
rendu hommage de l'avoir gagné vous
appartenez à celle qui vous convient je
m'en fous moi j'appartiens à celle-là
merci Bernard Tapie d'avoir été notre
invité
[Musique]